[Music]
let's go to liz in bangor maine what's
up liz
hey there dr john how are you so good
what about you
i'm living the dream are you really
what's that like
well i mean nightmares can be dreams too
so
i work on a podcast with james
so what's up i'm just kidding i love it
i'm living my dream i'm living my my bl
my best life
hey so what's up how can i help
so i have a question for you um
how can i cultivate self-discipline when
it comes to eating
are you setting me up i'm the worst
person to answer this call
yeah i've been listening for a little
while so i figured you might be one of
the best people so
i feel like you're making fun of me a
little bit liz but it's okay i'll go
with it
i'll go with it all right come tell me
about your relationship with food
well um i've always uh struggled with my
weight
starting
from the time i was probably a mid to
late teenager i've kind of just been
yo-yoing um
okay stop right there really
what was
what's what started the relationship
with food when you're a teenager did
something happen
no i think it's just my metabolism
caught up with me and
i just ended up gaining a bunch of
weight and then um
i think
there might have been i don't know it's
just kind of happened
yeah it kind of worked a little bit
you're about to say i've always been a
little bit larger than everyone else but
it just kind of um
it started catching up to me i guess
okay
so and how old are you
i'm 28 28 now okay
and then so you've been yo-yoing and
then what
um well i am sick of yo-yoing and i'm
trying to figure out ways to like i'll
get on
like i'll be really disciplined for a
shorter amount of time and then i'll get
off the bandwagon and like
um
i'll just gain all the weight that i
lost back and i can't i've been trying
to learn how to make sustainable
everyday
life changes that i can stick to because
you know i don't want to you know i'm
writing out my health in my 20s for sure
and i'm not going to be in my 20s
forever and my health is going to catch
up to me
so
do you like
yourself yes
tell me about that why do you like liz
because i'm adventurous and i'm fun and
i work hard
and
i
am a great
sister and daughter and friend
and employee and co-worker
so you told me a bunch of i don't have
filth you told me a bunch of external
metrics those are great performances why
do you like liz
you told me a lot of things liz does
especially for others what does liz do
for herself that she loves
um i work
i work hard
and i enjoy hiking
and backpacking i enjoy
spending time with my cat
and
i don't know
i'm a good i'm a student and i work hard
with
that do you have good character
i would say so yeah do you tell the
truth overall
mostly i mean mostly
um here's what i'm getting at i always
want to know if when someone's got a a
challenging relationship with food
um
is it
truly between the food or is it a
defense mechanism
for something else going on
i started tracking
um i've done this several times in my
adult life i started tracking my
food
intake and particularly around food that
i know is unhealthy for me and
a hundred percent
a hundred percent
of the times i mindlessly reach for
something whether it's chips or
ice cream or just
stinking tyler made his grandma's
cookies back here back in this
in the back studio here and
he was like i mean you just got to and i
did and
a hundred percent of the time
it's relational in nature or fatigue in
nature either i'm frustrated about
something i'm disconnected from somebody
my daughter just said a thing that for
some reason i decided to allow to hurt
my feelings my wife and i are off kilter
i'm frustrated with my son's math
teacher
um me and my boss are having
we're at odds
something relational in nature
it's it's a
unthinking i just go do
my body has learned this makes this
better for a minute
yeah
either that or the second one is i'm
exhausted
i'm so tired do either of those ring a
bell to you
um to an extent yes
if they don't it's all good that's just
the way that's that's just me following
the data of my n equals one experiment
with my body
what about you
um well i'm definitely
when you've talked in the past about you
know if there's a box of cookies open
and you just eat the entire thing um yes
i have that i have that problem
maybe not the gene to go with it who
knows but um i have that problem um i
know that
sometimes when i'm stressed or when i
just haven't
eaten in a while i'll be much more
likely to stop by and go get some fast
food or something which i've been
curbing pretty good lately okay um
but
so here's what the data tells me
a couple of different things and they're
they're across the board and i want to
preface this with saying i'm not a
nutrition expert and so i want to make
sure i don't get out over my skis here i
was going to talk to you about stuff in
my life okay and the folks that i've
walked alongside
the first thing this is relatively
recent i've talked about on the show
just a little bit um it made a lot of
sense to me
this idea of chronic stress that we are
running so hard and so fast and it's not
even so hard so fast relationally or at
work
we're in bodies that did not evolve to
drive 90 miles an hour to work among
other
2000 pound metal missiles that are
driving next to us
we're not designed for all of the
email clicks and the phone calls and the
text message we're just not designed for
all the assault of
um
marketing messages and you suck and you
should look like this and not that and
oh my gosh they're not your friend and
they didn't like my video and i don't
like them in the real world because they
didn't like me in my imaginary world
our
bodies
literally are not designed to live in
this world
and they've got crude response to stress
our body does fight flight
there's the fawning one which is which
is a different thing and freezing
what never occurred to me um gosh
james do you remember who this was it
huberman or atiya one of these smart
guys they're way way way 10x 100x
smarter than i am
it's talking about
if your body
recognizes it's in fight or flight it is
going to reach for the cheapest energy
source possible
because it's in search of cheap calories
that it can burn for energy right now
because it thinks it's in a fight or
that it is sprinting for its life
and the cheapest calories we got are
cookies and chips
right um sugar-laden carbohydrates that
are gonna help us get from a to b
what our
bodies don't know is that we're just
sitting on the couch watching netflix
we're watching somebody else getting
chased and murdered and but our body
sets off to try to defend ourselves
against somebody else's problems and if
we watch the news and scroll etc so
step number one is
no it's not step number one i'm gonna
say step number two step number two is
look at the world you've created your
ecosystem
are you taking care of you
are you stressed a lot are you flying
around a lot are you busy a lot
because if you are it might be that your
body's trying to take care of you does
that ring a bell or no tell me i'm off
uh the stress uh like the always busy or
stressed yes okay in general
so the next part is something i got from
james clear
and it rang more true to me than
anything else i've ever
i've ever read i've ever participated
and i've never ever internalized
and that's this
he wrote his book atomic habits i highly
recommend that people read that book
it's a great book but the biggest
takeaway for me from that book was this
most of us start
a weight loss goal a relationship with
food we start these things with a number
with a destination with a
goal and i know enough from the
psychology research is that these
external metrics these external things
are never sustainable because wherever
you end up
there you are right
so if you lose 20 pounds and you don't
like yourself you're gonna be 20 pounds
later and not like yourself
if you find yourself lonely and
disconnected without relationships and
you lose 50 pounds you're going to be
lonely and lose 50 pounds and at some
point your body's going to solve that
equilibrium
and it's going to try to it's going to
do what it can
to solve for that discomfort
and if you do drugs you do drugs if you
do food you do food if you work 90 hours
a week you work down here whatever you
pick your poison right
so what james clear says to do is
instead of starting with i want to lose
this much weight
or i want to eat
never eat sugar again or something like
that
he said start with creating a new
identity
and i do this every year
like this is part of my annual routine i
just look at my life how have i been
doing how's my relationship
what are the identities i want to adopt
this year
and so instead of saying i want to lose
a bunch of weight or instead of saying i
want to be less heavy or less big or i
want to have a better relationship with
food instead of starting there
i start with this
i'm a guy who stewards his one precious
body
that's who i am
and from there i'm gonna backfill things
like people who
honor their bodies who are good stewards
of their bodies they don't eat that
trash
people who are who are honored and
steward their bodies go to bed they
don't watch netflix another show on
another show another show by the way i
was up to like 1 30 doing edits on my
book
and i ended up watching an episode of
the office by the way it's the single
funniest episode it's in season eight i
didn't even remember it and i was
laughing so hard by myself at 2 am and i
was the whole time i'm thinking
what kind of
you have a show that you teach people
how to take care of themselves and i'm
up at 2 a.m watching tv you know what i
mean like um
so
start with an identity so you like
yourself and you should yeah you're a
good human being you're a great woman
and what do you do for a living
i work in ems
in ems
yeah on an ambulance
oh gosh
why didn't you lead with that
also
also deal with secondary traumatic
stress
good god almighty if you deal in other
people's trauma all day every day your
body is in fight or flight always
always
the number of times i left a wreck
and stopped at a gas station for just
some nonsense on the way home was a
lot right
uh-huh yes i'll leave with that next
time
so
here's here's the thing
i want you to spend some time this could
be writing it down it depends how far
you want to go i want you to write down
get a small little journal and write
down a couple of identities i'm somebody
who takes care of their body
i'm somebody who will show up to
somebody else's worst moment fully
present ready to rock and roll and so
since i'm that kind of person this is
what i have to do i have to
eat well
i have to not eat nonsense like that i'm
gonna backfill those things the numbers
on the scale will take care of
themselves if we live into the identity
that we want to have
and here's the other the third big one
you have to have to have to have people
who walk alongside you can't do life by
yourself
okay
do you have a couple of drivers that
would
join you on some sort of reimagination
like dude we are team x and this is just
how we roll this is who we are
um
they're all like screw you we're going
to mcdonald's forget it
they're not exactly the most supportive
when it comes to stuff and people bring
in goodies all day every day especially
around christmas because you know we
work at a fire department exactly the
worst they're the best and the worst
ugh
i know
let's start with the identity piece
let's start with getting a small journal
and i want every time you reach for
something i want you to stop and go what
am i feeling right now
am i disconnected am i exhausted
am i stressed
begin to ask yourself that it may not be
at all and if it's not
then it becomes a much simpler
transition
most of us have to find the gap between
impulse and action because if we can
find that gap we can pause in that gap
and then do another action that's how
you take control of your actions
okay and we do me one last favor
sure will you be so so
[Music]
graceful with liz
because i know that you say you like her
i think there's sometimes you don't like
liz
or sometimes you get really pissed off
or ashamed of liz is that true
um more so recently yes but this is more
chronic
here's the thing i don't fully believe
you i think you're hedging it but you're
on in front of a million people so i get
that too
listen i want you to be graceful with
liz
okay because liz is worthy of being
healthy
this is worthy of laughing a whole lot
she's worthy
of having a night where she just eats
garbage and gets up the next day and
goes again
she's also worthy of changing
everything
just because
just
because fair enough is that fair
i think so awesome remember one last
thing
your triggers
that's your roadmap
that's the gps towards getting well
so when you can identify those triggers
then you know to lean
man if you're having relationship
problems
now you know i got to go work on my
relationship problems if you're running
a doing a job that is high stress high
stress high stress high stress at some
point you go maybe this isn't the job
for me or i gotta do it a different way
or in a different capacity at a
different place because my body's saying
that's enough
but whatever it is you're worth it liz
and dude i'm gonna try i'm gonna try to
take care of myself
ubn too